you have a teenager and they've had a
rough few years first they were arrested
for shoplifting was an item of little
value only a misdemeanor but then your
teen was with some friends who were
smoking pot and driving way too fast
your teen has promised they're turning
over a new leaf and seem to be on the
right track doing better in school
coming home by curfew and generally
having a much better attitude but you
then get a call from the local police
station saying that your son was with a
group of kids who broke into a liquor
store and stole beer what do you
do well the first thing I do is go pull
up the uh GPS app I installed on my
son's phone secretly and have a look at
what he's been doing and confirm that he
was in fact at the liquor store on the
night that the police uh seem to think
uh of course I get that all packaged up
nice and neat to hand over to the police
officers uh but first I go to a sporting
goods store and I get a ski mask and a
baseball bat and then I wait until my
son sneaks out of the house and he's
going to do some
Shenanigans chase him down and I don't
mind you I'm just trying to scare him
but he's he's he's with his buddies
they're goofing around they're they're
drinking they're doing bad stuff I pull
up next to their parked car where
they're having some beers get out with
the ski mask and the baseball bat and in
a weird voice that would prevent my son
from understanding that it was
definitely me and somehow I'm not in my
car either I yell at them you break into
my liquor store and you steal from me
and I just [__] d destroy the car
with the baseball bat and the whole time
I hit it and I'm like that's from the
that's from my store you can't steal
from me you think you can steal from two
toast Johnny and I just [__] just
destroy the [__] out of this car even
though it's not my son's car just just
so these kids are freaked out they're
all grouped up they're backing away as I
destroy the car as soon as I'm happy
with the car turn at them with the
baseball bat still raised and I looked
at them like you never [__] come in
my store again
and then I take the ski mask off and I
go Brandon get in the car we're going to
the police station and I take him to the
police station and I give him the GPS
information and he goes to jail
probably whose car did you just beat the
[__] out of was that your sons one of
his stupid
friends I don't care if they know I did
it I don't give a
sh